accompagner le développement d'un enfant
autiste exige des compétences des
professionnels
parmi les différentes structures
d'accompagnement existantes à la réunion
il en existe une qui sort de l'ordinaire
un centre expérimental de services
d'accompagnement comportemental
spécialisés le sax cet établissement
propose une démarche unique à la réunion
et dans l'océan indien
un accompagnement basé sur une méthode
anglo saxon peu utilisé en france le à b
à la béa analyse du analyse appliquée du
comportement
c'est un outil qu'il va permettre
d'analyser les comportements d'une
personne en fonction de son
environnement
les interactions qu'elle peut avoir avec
son environnement donc c'est quelque
chose qui est indépendant de l'autisme à
la base mais qui a effectivement montré
d
des progrès significatifs anvers cette
population par rapport à
l'accompagnement des personnes de très
jeunes enfants des ados des adultes et
c'est cette méthode considère que
l'enfant apprend par les interactions
avec son environnement
l'enfant autiste est en capacité
d'apprendre l'établissement établit les
règles de cet environnement
l'adapt pour permettre l'apprentissage
et la meilleure sociabilisation possible
l'environnement effets de différents
stimuli que l'enfant autiste n'est
peut-être pas capable de gérer au début
en tout cas parce qu'il a un
fonctionnement cognitif différents donc
au début on va pouvoir effectivement
arranger l'environnement pour que ce
soit le plus simple pour lui mais l'idée
étant de très vite passé dans un
environnement le plus naturel possible
puisque ce qu'on veut c'est que l'enfant
autiste soient intégrés socialement et
intégré socialement ça veut dire
accepter toutes les stimulations de
l'environnement les professionnels qui
sont ici en une formation pour savoir
quoi observer chez l'enfant
comment observer et comment répondre à
ces comportements il suffit pas
effectivement d'être dans une
observation un enfant dans un
environnement et on le regarde faire
c'est aussi arrivé à décoder comprendre
pourquoi il ya ce comportement et nous
on fait partie de l'environnement
donc on va pouvoir agir sur ce
comportement là et c'est cette cette
action qu'on va avoir sur le sûr le
comportement de l'enfant qui va du coup
modifier son comportement pour agir
totalement sur l'environnement de
l'enfant
l'implication des parents dans le
processus est primordiale car une fois
rentré à la maison
il faut assurer la continuité de cette
méthode cette continuité est comprise
dans l'accompagnement du sax la méthode
d'abyane
consiste actuellement une soit plus de
même les mêmes méthodes pour lui ai dit
qu'il y ait si on bat la maison continue
à travailler à utiliser les mêmes
méthodes politiques viennent renforcer
des bons comportements
il lui demande de faire quelque chose et
qui de fait renforcé
donc on agit
et donc il ya toujours quelqu'un de 10
sec ce qui vient une fois par semaine à
la maison jours
en contre l'accompagnement de l'enfant
dont toutes les semaines au début ils
ont ce qu'on appelle une guidances
parentale ou on va à domicile pour voir
comment ça se passe aussi à la maison
parce que l'enfant peut avoir un
comportement différent à la maison 2 par
rapport au sax par rapport à l'école etc
donc c'est de comprendre avec eux de les
aider à comprendre le fonctionnement de
leurs enfants dans leur environnement
premier pour que le soir le week-end des
vacances il ne soit pas démuni face aux
comportements leurs enfants qu'ils
sachent comment y répondre et quoi
mettre en place cette méthode est encore
expérimentale mais les évaluations sont
formels cette méthode apporte des
résultats
qu'est ce qui prouve que ça marche les
résultats des évaluations puisqu'on a
des évaluations objectives c'est qu'un
enfant un enfant à n'a pas ce
comportement on veut lui enseigner tel
ou tel comportement
on met des stratégies d'enseignement en
place et deux semaines après il aimait
ce comportement de manière spontanée
c'est effectivement que ça fonctionne on
va dire est que l on a réussi à lui
enseigner un comportement il peut le se
l'approprier et s'en servir pour
communiquer notamment l'accompagnement
doit se faire jeunes et se veut être
court selon les études scientifiques et
plusieurs rapports de l'institut
national de la santé et de la recherche
médicale
au bout de quatre ans au maximum
l'enfant autiste peut être en capacité
d'insérer le milieu ordinaire pour paris
du sax dans ces deux d'accompagner un
enfant 3 4 ans et au bout de ces trois
quatre ans la d'envisager pour lui soit
le milieu ordinaire soit le milieu
protégé mais en tout cas qu'il est au
bout de ces trois quatre ans là le
maximum de compétences développées ce
projet est expérimental car en france la
méthode ab a fait encore débat dans la
communauté scientifique
cependant afin d'offrir une réponse la
plus diversifiée aux personnes
concernées par l'autisme
ce projet a été soutenu par la
collectivité quand nous avons démarré
mais il fallait créer une
association vous savez il fallait créer
une association loi 1901
donc voilà nous avons créé cette
association nous n'avions pas à ce
moment là puisque l'association a été
créée ans dans février 2007 nous
n'avions pas à ce moment-là d'argent
évidemment pas de subventions de l'état
comme maintenant alors il m'a fallu
aller demander aux collectivités et
notamment au conseil général de l'aide
pour pouvoir fonctionner parce que déjà
on avait recruté aussi des psychologues
pour aider les parents pour aider
l'association
c'est ce que c'est en tout cas le
conseil général a répondu positivement
comme aussi des subventions privées des
entreprises qui nous ont aidés
ce qui nous a permis d'attendre la
subvention et a depuis juillet 2010 mme
le service d'accompagnement
comportemental spécialisés est en
activité depuis près de cinq ans les
professionnels développe ici une
véritable expertise une ressource
supplémentaire pour les enfants autistes
et leurs familles